[Música]
nasceu maria maria crescia maria sorria
maria vivia sonho maria namorou maria
casa maria separou maria maria chorava
maria sofria morreu maria mas não é
poesia essa história da minha tia maria
10 mulheres boas e ruins e de sempre uma
delas porque tem que ser assim
meu nome é renata sou natural de goiânia
goiás e lá vivia temos 22 anos quando eu
penso nesse período da minha vida
logo me veio uma expressão shakesperiana
mente som e fúria é que o meu contexto
familiar
ele foi marcado pela presença soberana
do álcool
quem já conviveu com esse vício ou com
qualquer outro semelhante sabe do que
estou falando
parece que é uma mistura de sentimentos
que a gente tem é um amor
somada ao ódio somado à compaixão
parece que os nossos dias eles são
longos demais vivendo isso parece que as
nossas noites de trevas não acabam nunca
e parece que a gente que é de uma
maneira muito mágica acabar com o
sofrimento das pessoas que a gente mais
ama e no meu caso em especial a minha
realidade ela estava mais preso um
corredor em que eu passava os dias
tentando escutar por através de uma
porta o que estava acontecendo quando eu
nasci os meus irmãos já eram bem
grandinhos eles já sabiam que a
realidade deles estava mais focada e
entender que eles precisavam se
preocupar com as questões de
sobrevivência pra eles
aquele corredor longo e frio que já
tinha sido palco de coisas muito ruins
que o álcool pode trazer a convivência
de alguém já era algo
eles só queriam pôr fim aquilo tudo e
pra ele de certa forma a minha chegada
os aterrorizavam de uma certa forma
só que pra mim é a mãe que naquela época
já tinha desistido completamente de
viver nasceu algo diferente e na hora
inclusive de escolher meu nome
ela não titubeou ela escolheu renata
porque ela sentia que ela tinha nascido
de novo a minha mãe sem dúvida nenhuma a
pergunta que ela mais o viu na vida foi
mãe meu pai tá bebendo e a gente também
sem dúvida nenhuma o que a gente mais
ouviu foi sim seu pai tá bebendo e
parece que aquele sim ele vinha
acompanhado com uma nuvem escura
parece que aquela nuvem pairava na nossa
cabeça e estava tudo que acontecer dali
pra frente
se a gente estava fora de casa a gente
imaginava o que estava acontecendo lá
se a gente estava ali dentro a gente já
estava em meio ao caos
se meu pai não estava em casa a gente
ficava imaginando como ele ia chegar de
que forma se ele voltar aí de que forma
é que isso ia acontecer
lá a gente ia mais uma vez sofrendo com
toda essa situação mas de forma
surpreendente
tudo que o álbum poderia ter causado a
nossa família a minha mãe ela abrandou
isso de uma forma surpreendente pela sua
sabedoria a minha mãe não poupou esforço
nenhum no sentido de mostrar pra mim e
para os meus irmãos que todo ser humano
é ambíguo toda vez que eu questionava e
travar diálogos com ela no sentido de
lhe perguntar por que aquilo tudo
acontecia ela em todas as suas falas me
deixou de uma maneira muito clara e
muito certeira de que todo ser humano é
ambíguo e de que bastavam algumas
fagulhas pra que eu também me
despertasse para o bem e para o mal
e lá a gente ia mais uma vez buscar meu
pai
ora numa delegacia ora num bar
ora numa briga de rua num canto qualquer
a nossa expectativa não tinha muita
clareza era vivo ou morto que a gente
sempre esperava encontrar
eu até fiz muito pouco esse papel só que
a minha irmã mais velha eu acredito que
ela tenha não saiba contar quantas vezes
ela já fez isso em várias vezes ela
chegava para buscar meu pai e ela ele
nem reconhecia e às vezes ele até
insultava aí num dia não sabia quem era
ela e dizer coisas horríveis para ela e
voltando pra casa a cada coração partido
vinha à minha mãe dizendo que vale a
pena e que aquela era a nossa
experiência parece que ela vinha
costurando o nosso coração e dizendo que
aquilo era nossa história e em cada
diálogo todas as vezes eu falava mãe meu
pai é muito ruim
ela falava mas seu pai é muito bom e eu
falava o time se isso aqui agora o que
ele fez não tem lógica
na minha filha mas aquilo lá que ele fez
você viu tem toda a razão e aí hoje
quando eu paro para pensar eu acho que
ela tinha razão se ele tivesse sempre um
comportamento único unilateral por
exemplo para o lado ruim das coisas
seria tudo muito mais fácil tudo muito
mais simples muito mais previsível de se
lidar
ele era sempre ruim a gente saberia como
lidar mas só que o problema dele é que
ele grava de uma pessoa extremamente
ruim e raivosa agora daqui a pouquinho
se transformar em uma pessoa
extremamente bondosa e gentil com a
gente ea gente naquele misto de
sentimentos tinha vontade de correr
abraçar e tirar ele naquelas trevas que
parecia que ele estava
eu cresci e eu tive o prazer da
convivência muito aproximada com ela a
minha mãe ela sempre foi considerada uma
pessoa aconselhadora e ela não perdeu
nenhuma oportunidade de curtir as suas
crenças em mim e assim esse dilema
humano se fez muito presente na minha
vida de uma maneira muito forte muito
aproximada sempre e os anos passar
na minha casa aquele cenário não mudou
em goiânia
mas eu cresci namorei e vim para
blumenau
aquele dilema tudo aquilo que eu vivi
eu creio que seria difícil não fazer de
certa forma parte da minha vida
profissional e eu acabei dele nem dos
meus estudos na área de gestão de
pessoas na minha vida corporativa
atuando com gestão de pessoas em
especial eu buscava sempre entendeu os
comportamentos das lideranças porque é
que as lideranças impacto de uma maneira
tão forte na vida de quem trabalha
diretamente porque é assim porque é que
as coisas se desenrolam dessa maneira
ele por 2015 em 2016 especial
eu estava muito dedicada à elenca esses
comportamentos elenca de comportamento
essas pessoas tinham que ter para que
sejam mais favoráveis
o dia a dia sejam mais favoráveis às
suas práticas no dia a dia de seus
profissionais
e aí eu comecei a ver que muitas das
competências que eu percebia que faltava
por exemplo nesses profissionais tinha
em abundância em outros profissionais
que não necessariamente tinha uma
educação formal como a deles e eu
comecei a perceber também que a cada
nome que eu ia elencando a cada história
que eu ia percebendo não estava
necessariamente relacionado alguém que
eram um ícone de liderança que pra mim
eu tinha aprendido minha vida
corporativa aqueles exemplos na verdade
eles tinham muito mais a ver com as
mulheres da minha família que essas
outras pessoas que eu era acostumado a
estudar sobre a vida delas
parece que aquele sentimento de fazer
junto que buscava em um líder estava
presente na minha mãe na minha tia nas
minhas sobrinhas nas minhas irmãs na
minha prima na minha cunhada aquele zelo
pelo próximo
o cuidado de fazer de dizer algo que é
difícil reconhecer os seus erros
e ter um equilíbrio emocional diferente
quando a gente encontra um cenário que
não nos é favorável
parece que estava ali com elas
essas competências acontecendo de uma
maneira tão natural e parece que ao
mesmo tempo buscava isso de uma maneira
tão corporativa tão por meio de uma
educação formal
nessa mesma época precisamente em 2016
eu faria 30 anos e como projeto pessoal
eu imaginava escrever um livro
a minha ideia era escrever um livro de
crônicas femininas na minha ideia
meu pensamento eu escreveria um livro
era bastava planejar e tava tudo na
minha cabeça só que o projeto não
engrenou de maneira alguma
e daí como eu sou uma pessoa bastante
reflexiva
eu comecei a pensar poxa porque esse
negócio anda né não anda não anda porque
eu tô fazendo sozinha e não vai andar
nunca porque para mim é difícil fazer as
coisas sozinha pra mim ter alguém
curtindo uma mesma idéia faz todo
sentido
e aí como a gente é um ser integral né
ao mesmo tempo estava montando aquela
questão das competências no trabalho e
que tudo parece que começou a fazer
muito sentido competências essas
mulheres que disputavam como exemplo pra
mim essa questão do livro que não tava
andando mas eu estava sozinha e aí eu
tive um insight com relação a essas
questões todas mas quem são então essas
mulheres inspiradoras que além de ter
aqueles e aquelas competências que são
super inspiradoras para as lideranças
mas que trazem consigo outros
outros temas outros sentimentos que
estavam ali arraigados com elas e que de
certa forma nos unem de uma maneira toda
especial
além da minha mãe a minha tia e sua
filha às minhas irmãs e as suas filhas
ea minha cunhada
são sentimentos que eu via que também
estavam ali muitos focados sentimentos
bem variados que vão desde
transtornos alimentares amores não
correspondidos
a perda de um companheiro de uma vida
toda
aquele sentimento de culpa que invade a
sua alma quando alguém te chama
especialmente seu pai e você não atende
e logo você fique sabendo você fica
sabendo que ele morreu após o seu
chamamento não correspondido
o enfrentamento de uma calvície na
juventude e no meu caso em especial a
frustração de não conseguir lidar
direito com a incapacidade de não poder
doar um rim o meu irmão
logo eu não tenho um grupo com essas dez
mulheres e propôs meninas porque que
juntas a gente não escreve um livro
romance riram né
as outras acharam graça
outras nem sequer responderam no que eu
tinha pedido pra elas
só que pra mim na verdade foi um balde
de água fria metade de mim sonha outra
metade
senti vergonha metade de mim que era
outra metade sequer naquela frustração
que senti naquele momento eu comecei a
sentir de uma maneira muito forte
todas aquelas amarras invisíveis que o
álcool me trazia de uma maneira muito
mais presente
antes a sensação que dava era que a
gente estava preso em uma sala sem
janelas escura e que tinha apenas uma
porta mas que a gente estava presa num
canto amarradas e amordaçadas e a gente
não conseguia chegar até a saída
só que pouco a pouco cada uma foi
encontrando nesse projeto a sua
verdadeira catarse e eu em especial eu
acreditava que essas almas elas
precisavam ainda gritar para que elas
viveram e que ainda estimular a viver
eu acreditava
assim que a gente podia ver o novo
inspirar outras pessoas também o entre
pedras e raízes
ele não foi só um instrumento de
sublimação ele foi à luz que adentrou
aquela sala ele foi aquilo que diz que
desatou aquela marca invisível e que
tirou a gente dá lhe o livro entre
pedras e raízes
ele é formado pelos nossos poemas pelos
poemas de dez mulheres de uma mesma
família que à época tinha entre seus 11
64 anos que contam sobre temas diversos
as suas percepções acerca do e feminino
e suas relações com seu ambiente
a nossa expectativa com a entrega desse
projeto era enorme a gente sonhou muito
a gente sonhou com o prazo apertado a
gente queria fazer um uma festa de
lançamento
a gente gostaria de fazer o lançamento
em goiânia no dia da mulher e faltavam
seis meses pra isso
a gente se empenhou muito ninguém era
escritora
eu ouvi naquele início que as amarras e
diziam mais pra gente que eu não posso
porque eu não sei escrever eu não posso
porque não tem nada pra contar
eu não posso porque você está viajando
isso é algo impossível pra gente
só que nesse contexto de superação
a gente traz tudo que a gente podia tudo
a gente superou tudo o que a gente
gostaria de entregar naquele momento de
lançamento
só que quando eu e meu esposo fomos
buscar os 100 livros da editora
a gente esperava encontrar aquele livro
bonito de capa dura costurado colado
muito bonita
só que na verdade que a gente encontrou
a receber foi um amontoado de folhas
soltas parecer que todo aquele sonho que
a gente tinha alimentado e vivido todo
aquele tempo estava desmanchando nas
nossas mãos e mais do que rapidamente eu
fui tentar colocar o meu desespero em
palavras para o pessoal da editora
e ainda bem que deu certo porque no
outro dia no dia anterior ao lançamento
foi que a gente buscou esses livros a
gente embarcou para goiânia para poder
fazer a tão sonhada festa com
estratégias para o lançamento desse dia
sem que ninguém soubesse do que tinha
acontecido na minha expectativa eu
imaginava que nós teríamos como todos os
outros momentos que dessa nossa
experiência o momento coletivo um
momento de congraçamento juntas e não
foi isso que aconteceu
quando cheguei com as obras em mãos
parece que cada uma foi para o seu canto
cada um naquele momento se recolheu e
foi desatada o seu próprio nó nos
preocupamos com o passado e com futuro
assim tornamos o nosso presente é um
lugar inseguro nos agarramos aquilo que
no passado não sei sofrer e nos
esquecemos de que hoje é o melhor dia
para se viver um passado sofrido nos
traz amargura amargura na alma aquela
que nos dê segura nos olhamos no espelho
e vemos uma figura fria sem emoção
porque se agarrou ao passado e destruir
seu coração
devemos então ter vindo com o manual de
instrução
mas se não foi assim
o que pensar então sobre mim
a festa de lançamento do livro foi
inesquecível
a gente se sentiu muito feliz com aquele
momento mas muito mais que ter aquela
festa e conseguir aquilo que a gente
tanto almejou foi perceber que a gente
conseguiu cumprir a nossa missão
literária que foi provocar reflexões por
meio da nossa produção e tocar
profundamente a alma das pessoas que
fizeram contato com os nossos
sentimentos
ora se identificando com um ou com outro
poema e assim a gente percebe o com
paradoxal
e contraditória pode ser a nossa
existência mas será que de fato ela
necessariamente precisa se resumir
apenas som e fúria
obrigada
[Aplausos]